And then behind those two things,
behind the shadow and the anima and the
Animus,
there is a final archetype,
which is the archetype of the self and
that's young,
believed that the self was what you were
as a totality and that's a hard thing to
understand,
but,
but you could think about it this way.
You could think about the self as the,
as the total of what you are now,
plus the total of all those things that
you could still be.
So it would be you as a reality plus us
potential.
And that's a strange idea,
right?
Because we don't really know how to
understand the idea of potential as
modern empirical people because
potential virtually by definition is not
yet manifest.
And also not a straightforward thing to
either measure or conceptualized.
By the same token,
everybody acts as if they're,
they have potential unrealized
potential.
And so young generated up a category to
account for that which he felt was
expressed in all sorts of symbolic
weight.
So for example,
the wise old man,
like,
like the wizards in the movies that all
of you have seen in the last five years.
It's always the same wizard.
Sometimes it's even the same actor.
It's like that's an archetype of the
wise old man and for young Christ was an
archetype of the self as well and I.
I told you why that was to some degree
and it's partly because the phoenix is
also an archetype of the self because
the Phoenix is something that can die
and be reborn and so the Phoenix stands
for the part of your personality that
can let one thing go.
One part of you which is in the live
part,
can let that go and burn up so to speak
so that something new can be born
because you very seldom gain something
before you let something else go,
but that's partly because what you
already assume can be the worst
impediment that you have to to learning
something new.
And it's complicated because sometimes
what you know worked in the past,
you know,
so you can think about that.
Maybe you're a perfectly well adapted 11
year old and you're still acting that
way when you're 15.
It's like,
well,
it's hard to let that go because it
worked and you put a lot of effort into
it,
but unless you let it go,
the new personality isn't going to be
able to manifest itself,
so you have to stop being a child before
you can be an adult and there is a
sacrifice that goes along with that.
It's also a sacrifice that parents have
to make,
right?
Because in order for a parent to
encourage you to adopt the
responsibilities of an individual,
they have to allow you as a child to
die.
And Freud's observation on that
phenomena was that many parents and he
believed this was particularly
characteristic of mothers because of
their tight bond with their children and
the dependency that that implies that it
was particularly difficult for a mother
to let her child die so that an adult
could manifest itself in that child's
place.
And that's fundamentally in many ways
the EDA pool complex.
Okay,
so now I'm going to show you some of
these things again,
because the thing about young is that
it's not easy to understand what he has
to say and it's not a simple thing to
explain it,
and his books are complicated,
although I don't think there are any
more complicated than they have to be.
Like I don't think young is obscure.
I think he's just difficult and then
beyond difficult.
He's actually frightening.
So there's lots of reasons that people
don't like you.